devic scénario
bonjour et bienvenue dans ce numéro d'
europe hebdo nous sommes à strasbourg au
coeur du parlement européen dans
quelques instants nous serons avec deux
invités pour commenter l'actualité
et dans cette émission focus sur les
producteurs de vins français qui sont
vent debout à l'idée de voir les
producteurs américains utiliser
l'appellation château mais d'abord
l'actualité dominée par la crise en
italie mario monti a décidé de jeter
l'épongé mais les italiens peuvent-ils
vraiment se passer de lui c'est la
question de la semaine
je ne me présente pas pour le poste de
président du conseil
je brigue simplement un siège à la
chambre des députés où de théâtre numéro
un
silvio berlusconi fait son retour sur la
scène politique italienne
il estime qu'il doit reprendre en main
son pays ravagé par la crise au
parlement son parti membre de la
coalition au pouvoir a boycotté un vote
de confiance
fustigeant la politique économique menée
par un gouvernement de techniciens ou de
théâtre numéro 2 quelques heures après
les déclarations du cavalière et mario
monti annonce sa décision irrévocable
le président du conseil italien estime
qu'il n'aura pas assez de soutien pour
faire voter sa loi budgétaire il jette
l'épongé
des élections anticipées auront lieu en
février ou mars prochain à 76 ans silvio
berlusconi se présentera pour la sixième
fois devant les italiens adapté à son
âge il devrait partir à la retraite
comme tout le monde les italiens n'ont
plus un sou à dépenser concrètement il
n'y a eu que des nouvelles taxes créées
et les salaires sont restées les mêmes
que ceux d'il ya dix ans retour en
arrière novembre 2011 silvio berlusconi
est président du conseil mis en cause
dans une affaire de moeurs
il doit démissionner le président
georgio napolitano appel au pouvoir
l'ancien commissaire européen mario
monti érigé en sauveur de l'italie mais
le professeur monty entouré d'experts
entame une cure d'austérité sans
précédent
le chômage augmente les impôts aussi
la consommation baisse le pays s'enfonce
dans la récession
pourtant l'italie après vingt ans de
berlusconisme retrouve son rang parmi
les nations européennes
aujourd'hui mon pti s'en est allé mais
pour combien de temps va-t-il se
représenter lui aussi car l'italie
peut-elle vraiment se passer de lui
retour à strasbourg nous sommes à deux
pas de l'hémicycle et un député italien
nous a rejoints niccolo rinaldi bonjour
vous êtes florence vous avez été élu sur
la liste du juge di pietro et vous
siégez ici comme député européen au sein
de l'alliance des démocrates et des
libéraux pour l'europe et vous parlait
très bien français
voilà comme ça on vous a présenté alors
essayons de comprendre un peu la
situation confuse dans laquelle se
trouve l'italie d'abord pour répondre à
notre question est ce que vous pensez
que l'italie peut se passer de mario
monti
oui je pense que l'italie peut se passer
le mal est monté ma demande t a été le
représentant d'un gouvernement
exceptionnelle d'urgence n'a jamais été
élu par les citoyennes italienne il a
effectué une politique qui en italie on
juge un peu un peu trop sur le modèle
allemande c'est à dire une politique
d'austérité très fortes donc les pays
sur certaines choses a sans aucun doute
un besoin mais qui a plié les deux
piliers de notre société la famille d'un
côté et les petites moyennes entreprises
beaucoup de taxes pas des
libéralisations ce qui est par contre ce
serait nécessaire pas d'aidé
bureaucratisation de la société
italienne qui est très importante parce
que nous avons une administration
publique extrêmement lourde de normes
pour lutter contre la corruption qui est
colossale dans notre pays qui ont été
assez faibles et je dirais une lutte
contre l'évasion fiscale ce qui est un
autre anomalie de mon pays qui n'a pas
été vraiment très efficace
aujourd'hui les bilans n'est pas
vraiment positive la dette augmente le
chômage augmente et la croissance n'est
pas là mais il a quand même fait des
réformes qui étaient nécessaires pour le
pays
il a fait une réforme qui était
ah non celle des retraites exactement
celle celle des retraites
avec quelques problèmes là aussi et je
dois dire que c'était une réforme très
important moi je peux vous dire que je
suis vie quand même la démarche de mon
parti mon parti quand parti de centre
gauche laïc qui a au parlement européen
siège dans l'alliance des libéraux et
démocratiques avaient voté la confiance
au gouvernement montrent qu'il y a un an
avec beaucoup d'espoir beaucoup
d'attentes et ensuite de différentes
mesures que le professeur a présenté au
pas vraiment on a constaté une déception
croissante il ya toute une série de
choses sur lesquelles on n'est pas
intervenue on continue à dépenser
énormément par exemple dans les dépenses
militaires
on n'a rien fait au niveau des grands
capitaux qui sont rentrés en italie avec
une pratiquement un bonus sans aucune
pénalisation de l'étranger des paradis
les paradis fiscaux
on n'est pas réussi à faire un accord
bilatéral avec la suisse et on a quand
même insisté beaucoup je répète sur la
pratique manière entreprises et sur la
famille ça marche pas mais aujourd'hui
est ce que mario monti et victime de la
crise économique ou des dernières
frasques si je puis dire de silvio
berlusconi et les victimes d'une
coalition qui l'a soutenu jusqu'à hier
qui est en contradiction en soi même
parce que c'est un coalition avec le
centre droite les centre gauche ensemble
cyclos des risques honni le peuple de la
liberté a soutenu la coalition dans les
rocheuses qu'ailleurs jusqu'à hier avec
ce qu'en italie 10 ans c'est un peu leur
attente parti socialiste le parti
démocratique l'équivalent du parti
socialiste quelque part français vous
souhaitez pas c'était une anomalie cette
coalition c'est ça aussi c'est une tout
à fait que c'est une grande anomalie et
ces deux regroupements bon ces contrats
posées aux prochaines élections il faut
se rappeler que l'échéance naturelle du
mandat c'était le mois d'avril
donc là on a des élections anticipées
mais c'est des élections anticipées dans
moi ça ne change pas énormément par
rapport à ce que de toute façon on
aurait été arrêté
le cas monde qui a pu gouverner
je dirais jusqu'à jusqu'à aujourd'hui
avec cette coalition que je répète avait
quand même tout le temps des problèmes à
son intérieur
c'est par la nature même de la coalition
et s'approchant la campagne électorale
je m'attendais je dois dire ça mais
tombe pas trop que berlusconi a eu lieu
lundi de reprendre sa liberté de
d'action politique vous pensez qu'il va
vraiment se représenter une nouvelle
fois devant les italiens je dirais que
cette décision de mon point de vue c'est
tout à fait ridicule parce que il était
candidat en 1994 la première fois alors
vous voyez combien ces vieilles la
politique italien toujours le même
personne toujours la même formule etc
il est capable quand même d'insister et
de se représenter en 2000 en 2013 dans
l'année prochaine les ego sont très
forts dans les hommes politiques et
mario monti on évoque on évoque une
possibilité pour lui de se présenter
vous y croyez donc lui il peut pas se
présenter dans peau nue formelle parce
que les sénateurs avis c'est une
fonction que nous avons dans notre pays
le président de la république pour
nommer jusqu'à cinq personnalités une
certaine stature reconnu par tout le
monde pour leur prestige sénateurs pour
toute la vie et donc c'est le cas de
2006 montre donc lui peut pas être
candidat il pourrait conduire une
coalition plus ou moins centriste mais
alors ça ça va mélanger bousculé
beaucoup la vie politique italienne
parce que il sera opposé soit par
berlusconi qui l'a soutenu jusqu'à hier
soit par les partis démocratiques qui a
son propre candidat qui a gagné le
primaire du centre gauche qui l'a
soutenu jusqu'aujourd'hui
alors on suivra ce feuilleton en tout
cas l'actualité européenne c'est aussi
cette europe qui malgré la crise a reçu
le prix nobel de la paix pour avoir su
maintenir plus de 65 ans de paix sur le
continent les 27 dirigeants européens le
président de l'union européenne le
président de la commission européenne et
le président du parlement européen sont
tous venus à oslo l'image qui était à la
une
des télévisions européennes regardez
le premier ministre irlandais et son
homologue néerlandais ont tous vers la
délégation des leaders européens aussi
sio d'oslo mais ce sont les présidents
du conseil de la commission et du
parlement qui ont reçu le prix donné à
l'union européenne pour son rôle en
faveur de la paix le comité du nobel a
expliqué que l'europe s'est construite
grâce à la réconciliation franco
allemande qui a fait que la guerre entre
les deux pays est devenu impensable
un rassemblement a été organisé samedi 8
décembre dans la capitale norvégienne
les manifestants ont critiqué les ventes
d'armes européennes dans les zones de
conflit le manque d' aide aux réfugiés
et l'absence de mesures sociales face à
la crise
pour les dirigeants européens c'est le
menu est aussi l'occasion de défendre ce
que l'europe a déjà accompli et ce
qu'elle espère pour le futur aujourd'hui
il l'un des symboles les plus visibles
de notre unité est dans les mains de
tous
je parle de l'euro la monnaie de notre
union européenne nous la défendrons les
trois présidents européens ont fait le
déplacement à oslo
leur trio symbolise la complexité de
l'union le conseil la commission et le
parlement ces trois institutions qui ont
parfois bien du mal à donner une
direction commune aux 27 aujourd'hui les
dirigeants européens sont presque tous
là nul merkel hollande me tiraille la
manquer 2 le président de la république
tchèque et le premier ministre
britannique david cameron représenté par
son numéro deux nick clegg le signe des
divisions qui traversent l'europe
alors il y avait vraiment beaucoup de
monde à oslo
mais finalement à qui s'adresse ce prix
nobel vous diriez plutôt aux dirigeants
européens actuels ou aux pères
fondateurs d'hier j'irais plutôt à la
collectivité à la communauté européenne
en tant que femmes et hommes qui la
composent
je pense que nous avons un premier
devoir à l'égard de l'europe c'est de
connaître notre histoire et notre
histoire ce n'est pas une histoire
entièrement positive l'aï beaucoup de
belles choses faites par l'europe
pendant les siècles des siècles au goût
des civilisations mais on a connu je
dirais deux mille ans de guerres civiles
européennes 2000 ont interrompu soit des
violences ce soit des dominations dn sur
les autres tout ça s'est arrêté avec les
pères de l'europe il ya cinquante ans
plus ou moins et les peuples européennes
ont démontré quand même la maturité la
capacité de rester en paix pendant
toutes ces décennies ce qui est tout à
fait sans précédent dans l'histoire de
l'europe
il a eu un certain nombre de polémiques
sur l'assignation à l'europe de ce prix
nobel
il ya certains qui disait que l'europe
mérite ne mérite pas ça mérite à mon
avis le mérite parce que si on lit le
les explications la justification du
prix nobel
il s'adresse pour ce qui a été achevé au
sein de l'europe
pas pour le rôle de puissance l'épée
dans le monde sait que avec les hits
l'hésitation que nous avons connu dans
les balkans dans le moyen-orient
c'est quelque chose sur laquelle europe
n'a pas vraiment été une grande
protagonistes mais au sein de l'europe
franchement on a vraiment achevée
quelque chose sans précédent dans notre
histoire mais alors au delà de cet
acquis fondamental est ce que ce prix
n'est pas aussi une forme
d'avertissement ou en tout cas une
incitation à agir pour sortir de cette
crise dans laquelle l'europe est
empêtrée depuis plus de deux ans et demi
maintenant moi je le prends comme un
encouragement comme une reconnaissance
ce que l'achat que les peuples les
européennes avec le père fondateur avait
fait dans les années 50 était le choix
juste et un encouragement pour essayer
de dépasser
ces cortèges qui nous a vendu dans notre
dame autre de votre service c'est-à-dire
toute cette cacophonie de chefs d'état
chef du gouvernement en discussion au
parlement de la commission et tous les
états tous les états membres alors ça
franchement c'est vraiment la complexité
ça peut marcher
ça peut pas marcher le schéma
institutionnel de l'europe a bien sûr
d'ailleurs c'est il faut pas même pas un
prix nobel pour pour faire ça ça suffit
regardez la croissance incroyable de la
chine sur la scène internationale
d'ici 20 ans l'europe en tant que tel
soit existe unis soit ça sera une petite
provence avec un certain nombre d petit
état membre sans vraiment beaucoup de
pouvoir nous dans les commerces ni dans
la politique étrangère a ni pour le
bien-être de leurs propres citoyens
c'est l'union total ou le chaos je pense
que c'est soit l'union politique union
guidée de valeur soit c'est le
airs et les vans c'est aussi ça le
message de ce prix nobel merci beaucoup
niccolo rinaldi d'avoir été avec nous on
va rejoindre tout de suite n'aura hamadi
qui sera avec le député eric andrieu
pour la deuxième partie de cette
émission met d'abord le reportage avec
cette question la mention château sur
les vins est elle menacée
en tout cas les états unis ont demandé à
la commission européenne l'autorisation
d'exploiter cette dénomination pour
leurs vins exportés en europe
touche pas à mon château c'est un sujet
signé betty lachguer et gwenaël durand
bouliac une des grandes appellations du
médoc
ici plus de mille hectares de vignes
s'étendent sur la commune dont celle de
la famille cazes
si le bâtiment n'y ressemble pas c'est
pourtant un château qu'il possède dans
le bordelais c'est ainsi qu'on nomme les
vins qui proviennent à 100% de raisins
récoltés sur la propriété
la définition de château reste bien
encadrés par opposition à man négoce
c'est un vin qui est
fabriqué à partir de raisins qui
viennent une seule et même exposé au
château lynch-bages le vin est tout
simplement un art de vivre un plaisir et
chaque visiteur vient découvrir son
vieux cuvier s'est elle étonnée qu'il
est fabriqué sur place et tout est fait
chez nous et surtout son grand cru dans
un premier temps de découvrir donc
ormes de pez qui se situe donc à
saint-estèphe pleuvant leur montrer
les pas engueuler entrée 5
très
les dénominations château clos et
domaine remonte au 19e siècle aux yeux
du grand public c'est aujourd'hui
synonyme de qualité puisque 80 % des
vins bordelais arbore cette étiquette un
repère dont pour les consommateurs est
un gage de savoir-faire pour les
vignerons
le mot est devenu une sorte de marque je
peux pas un exemple qui n'est pas
théorique est extrêmement fréquents vous
avez même propriété qui va appeler son
vin blanc château ceci est pour son vin
au château ceci donc ça correspond
simplement à une unité foncière est un
type de vin qu'il aime cette unité
foncière
un patrimoine qui pourrait bientôt être
en péril car les américains veulent
utiliser cette dénomination sur leurs
bouteilles
la demande a déjà été faite à la
commission européenne en attendant le
vote les viticulteurs bordelais
s'élèvent contre cette demande
bernard farges possède lui aussi une
propriété sous le nom du domaine de
l'enclos 90 hectares de vignes dans la
petite commune de mauriac à 50 km au sud
de bordeaux
et ce patrimoine il veut tout simplement
le protégé que les américains veuillent
utiliser cette dénomination authume
françois une très bonne nouvelle ça veut
dire que les identifie cette
dénomination comme un outil commercial
qui peut être puissant pour eux sauf
qu'ils veulent utiliser sa s'attribuer
les contraintes que les européens et les
français en l'occurrence se sont remises
pour la dénomination château s'ils ont
ce début d'hiver les vignes sont au
repos bernard farges s'activent car il
est aussi le président de la commission
nationale des appellations d'origine
contrôlée et organise des réunions de
canton le moment d'évoquer des sujets
d'actualité avec ses collègues
viticulteurs
au sein de l'europe qui a intérêt à le
faire remettre et une pression si forte
que ça les américaines pour accepter
comme par hasard septembre que les 25
chez les nouveaux dégagements avec un
ratio c'est un millésime puisse tomber m
puis sa rentrée sur le marché américain
ce qui était interdit dans les amériques
même si elles auront donc notamment
derrière cette ouverture de rodez c'est
tôt possible après roland une demande
qui serait donc le fruit de négociations
selon les viticulteurs français
côté américain difficile d'avoir leur
sentiment sur la question
seul thomas ce qu'est né a pu nous
répondre un chauffeur originaire de
boston il habite depuis deux ans et demi
avec sa compagne ils sont tous les deux
propriétaires de 65 hectares de vignes
et pour lui cette dénomination est
purement commerciale
je pense que le fait que l'industrie
viticole américaines puissent utiliser
le terme château c'est simplement du
marketing et ce serait un vol de
l'héritage français
car si vous demandez aux gens autour de
vous d'où vient à 20 dont le nom
commence par château je suis presque sûr
que 90 % d'entre eux et dire est qu'il
vient de france
reste encore d'autres interrogations
comme une utilisation du mot château en
français et non en anglais et pourquoi
les américains ne pourrait-il pas
utiliser cette mention en assumant les
mêmes règles qu'en france comme c'est le
cas au chili par exemple des questions
qui pourraient revenir sur le devant de
la scène de l'union européenne
et voici donc pour ce reportage réalisé
par betty lachgar au pied des vignobles
bordelais nous sommes donc toujours au
parlement européen et entre temps eric
andrieu nous a rejoints bonjour bonjour
merci d'être avec nous vous êtes donc
députés au sein de ce parlement depuis
six mois environ
vous êtes membre de la commission
agriculture et développement rural et
surtout vous êtes issu d'une terre de
vignerons si je puis dire
on a bien vu dans ce reportage que
l'appellation château pour les
américains posent problème pourtant le
chili et le canada l'utilisent d'ores et
déjà donc pourquoi cette fronde mais je
crois qu'il faut d'abord vérifier que
les que les conditions sont requises
pour l'utilisation de l'appellation sont
les mêmes pour tout un chacun
rock c'est le cas aujourd'hui en matière
de réglementation pour le chili entre
autres que vous faites de référence et
le canada est aujourd'hui pour ce qui
est de la demande et les américains rien
n'est rien n'est prouvé
il souhaite raison que le comité de
gestion donc de deux dossiers de munich
a été saisie pour vérifier si réellement
les conditions requises et elle était
réelle
il est bien clair que c'est un sujet
grave d'envergure pour la viticulture
française et s'est dit expressément dans
le reportage excellemment je pense qu'il
faut que nous soyons vigilants sur cet
héritage culturel donc telle sorte que
le l'avantagent produit par sept
mentions dont ne soit pas bradé en tous
les cas utilisez donc uniquement pour
des raisons de marketing comme il est
fait état aussi dans le reportage
et pourtant ce qu'on voit ce qu'il ya
quand même eu un deal aussi bien entre
les états unis et l'union européenne fin
du moins la france il ya depuis quelques
années en fait le millésime est le
cépage
peuvent être indiqués sur les bouteilles
pour la production française qui a
profité aux exportations aux etats-unis
est-ce que c'est pas juste retour des
choses c'est au coeur de la description
ma part que la question de l'utilisation
de la mention au château fait référence
avec les terres bien précis c'est à dire
qu'il faut et comme tout à lui le sait
dans la profession dans tous les cas il
faut à la fois que le raisin soit donc
sur l'exploitation et que la
transformation du raisonnable elle se
fasse sur l'exploitation elle même est
là pour l'instant n'est à ce jour d'un
grain et j'ai saisi pour cela entre
autres à travers une question écrite la
commission qui ne m'a pas répondu
réellement à la question afin de savoir
si éléments si ces éléments là et est
donc garantie dans la réponse qu'ils
allaient être apportées alors qui des
accords commerciaux d'autres ordres oui
mais concernant la mention château je
pense que c'est un sujet sur lequel il
faut qu'on l'ouvré je le redis vigilant
parce qu'au delà même du produit 20 ça
peut très vite dérivé sur une en nombre
de produits protégés donc pour la france
sur lesquelles il faut pas tout
confondre nos salles il peut y avoir des
accords commerciaux globaux un beau
livre de référence
mais sur ces aspects là je crois qu'il
faut que nous soyons très attentifs
alors il ya pour l'instant la commission
européenne a reporté sa décision la
france tout cela me paraît assez isolé
sur cette position
est-ce que c'est pas juste un répit de
courte durée est ce que finalement la
commission ne va pas aller dans le sens
des états unis écoutez pour l'instant
donc moi j'attends impatiemment donc je
vous dis l'avis du comité de gestion de
l'eau c'est à munich dans mon cas et
l'avis de la commission parce que tout
ça est en travaux alors il ya plusieurs
sujets s'ils le font quand même je
voulais me de rien l'union
oui mais je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient
pin des landes solidaire malgré tout
derrière ce que représente de la mention
châteaudun
dans la france quoi voilà parce que si
vous voulez une question se pose plus
largement au delà de la mention château
sur la notion de territoire et de marque
cette question-là en développement rural
en particulier de comment mettre un
dynamique des filières économiques que
l'on parle du vin mais ça peut toucher
d'autres produits en soit le fromage
tous les produits transformés finalement
donc
donc c'est une vraie question en matière
de développement rural il est non pas de
protection c'est du protectionnisme mais
de protection sans d'appropriation des
spécificités avait la volonté
d'ouverture donc sur les marchés dans
des internationaux et la question de la
mention viennent au coeur du débat
aujourd'hui bon nombre d'acteurs et
réfléchi ce fait les marques
territoriales telles qu'on les appelle
comme qualifie qui viennent faire
comment dire l'alchimie entre des
marques de produits donc une approche et
identitaire et géographique c'est les
aop pour des produits les ige pédant
mais au delà il ya les enjeux des
rapports au patrimoine tous les
territoires sont en concurrence
aujourd'hui c'est même une question
d'identité points derrière tout ça n'est
pas une insulte au sens du repli mais au
sens donc la spécificité de lieux et
l'ouverture aux autres
alors justement dans le cadre de ce
marché qui est quand même un marché
international nous avons rencontré
quelqu'un qui a une question à vous
poser on écoute on va avoir des vins qui
sont des vins de qualité avec des
méthodes bordelais revoir avec des
cépages bordelais qui sont produits à
des prix bien inférieurs sur les marchés
étrangers c'est pas sur les marchés
français qui se passait c'est notamment
sur le marché anglais ce marché allemand
sur le marché belge sur le marché
américain bien entendu et ça c'est le
problème des différences de coûts de
production entre les pays
régionale eric andrieu est ce que la
france a perdu la bataille du vin sur le
marché international je ne le crois pas
je ne le crois pas et sur cette question
là la question du moment qu et celles
liées aux droits de plantation est au
coeur donc du sujet était un dossier
effectivement la libéralisation des
droits de plantation c'est bien
évidemment j'ai l'occasion d'y apposer
donc de mettre tout tout est lié
finalement sur libéralisme je pense
qu'ils vont pour la france serait était
donc quelque chose de catastrophique ne
sont pas au bout donc on va dire du
feuilleton puisque donc le le groupe dit
de haut niveau qui a été réuni par le
commissaire dacian ciolos réuni vendredi
le 14 donc décembre et nous aurons une
réponse il semblerait que la réponse
soit plutôt favorable et même si on
n'appelle pas ça des droits de
plantation ça va prendre plus de ça
prendrait plutôt la dénomination
d'autorisation d'implantation mais avec
tous les éléments de critères requis
donc pour la par la profession donc ce
qui veut dire en fait qu'on reviendrait
en fait on sur ces droits de plantation
sur cette libéralisation on mettre en
place des quotas comment ça se passe
tout à fait oui seulement ont rétabli un
principe que les droits à part qu'on
appelle reppas a des droits mais avec la
volonté de régulation donc sur le sur le
marché il n'aura la réponse vendredi
et est ce qu on sait combien emplois
sont liés à cette production de vin en
france et au plus large en europe
alors ça c'est difficile à comptabiliser
pascal a produit à l'emploi direccte
donc liés à la filière donc il ya tout
ce qui tourne autour des emplois induits
quoi comment l'état non mais dans le
bordelais s'est déjà 56 à 60 mille
emplois donc ça veut dire ce que voilà
on mesure ce que ça représente
comme je comment dire je
je mets boutabout bordelais la nodo
cautionne le grand dessus de sud ouest
vient de lancer conscription 150 mille
emplois directs et donc les droits de
plantation et cette appellation château
risquerait de mettre à mal en fait c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous perdions sur les
deux tableaux à la fois celui de la
mention est celui des droits
effectivement je pense que la filière
viticole surimi jamal pour la france
alors rapidement dernière question je
reviens sur la question je vous posais
tout à l'heure est ce que la france face
aux vins australiens sud américains nord
américain n'a pas un petit peu perdu la
bataille
non sincèrement je ne crois pas la
france est riche de la qualité de ses
terroirs
c'est pour cette raison que la question
de la mesure est aussi importante série
contenant une place à l'international
lié à nos spécificités territoriales sur
la dimension je pense que c'est pas que
c'est pas qu'une vue de l'esprit quoi je
pense qu'il faut vraiment donner la
balle à la bataille avec force et
véhémence telle que nous le faisons les
uns et les autres parce que il en va de
l'avenir la spécificité de l'agriculture
française et de la viticulture française
merci beaucoup eric andrieu d'avoir été
notre invité est on suivra de toute
façon cette problématique pour nous
c'est la fin de cette émission on se
retrouve très bientôt en janvier sur les
chaînes parlementaires pour un nouvel
épisode d' europe hebdo et d'ici là
bonne suite de programmes et surtout
bonne fête